here's a question for you scp-explained
fans what do the following items have in
common a romance novel about long-dead
kfc founder colonel harlan sanders a
27-pound bucket of mac and cheese
radioactive uranium ore and a wallet
that looks like a pair of tidy whities
with skid marks you can buy them all on
amazon
amazon it's one of the world's largest
online retailers famous for its wide
range of products and services it's
generally pretty reliable delivery and
it's appalling treatment of its workers
it's also really really weird seeing as
almost anyone can set up a store on
amazon and the fact that it's one of the
most popular storefronts in the world
it's natural that a huge number of
lovable nutcases would set up shop and
ply their super bizarre trade there's
such a breadth of weird items you can
buy on amazon that it seems almost
anomalous and nobody knows this better
than one of the scp foundation's
greatest and most eccentric researchers
dr jack bright what does dr bright have
to do with weird amazon purchases it's a
hell of a story and it begins like many
stories at the scp foundation do with
scp-680
the hard to destroy reptile reaching
containment and killing a hell of a lot
of people this latest containment breach
actually comes as a result of what one
might professionally call a major
boo-boo by junior researcher elliot
hayburg sadly for young dr hayburg this
actually happened on the first day of
his new research assignment on the
scp-682 termination project which seemed
about as likely to bear fruit as
attempts to find pots full of leprechaun
gold at the end of nearby rainbows of
course carried out by mtf omega 420 also
known as the luck of the irish but
that's another video entirely needless
to say as he helped the janitorial staff
mop up all the blood while a group of
guards carried a heavily injured 682
back to its cell dr hayburg felt pretty
bummed about this whole situation of
course the loss of life caused by
hayberg's cross test was a tragedy but
he also felt terrible for letting his
bosses down on his first day aside from
quite literally dying or being given a
fate worse than death by some horrifying
anomaly this was really the worst day to
start a first day at the scp foundation
dr bright a foundation veteran by
anyone's definition noticed that dr
hayburg was looking upset and decided to
go and offer some sage advice while also
taking an opportunity to tell one of his
trademark tall tales was it a true story
who knows but it was certainly true that
it was a story don't beat yourself up dr
bright said giving dr hayburg a
comforting fatherly pat on the shoulder
682 gets out and kills a bunch of people
every month it's no biggie i've made way
bigger mistakes than this compared to
the amazon incident this is nothing the
advice immediately made dr hayburg feel
a little better but he was also
immediately curious replying the amazon
incident i can't say i'm familiar with
that almost as though dr bright had only
comforted dr hayburg in the first place
to give himself an opportunity to tell
his story he sat the junior researcher
down and immediately began to spin his
yarn a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away dr bright was having one of his
rare slow days he sat around his office
occasionally spinning around on his
office chair and contemplating life the
universe and everything the funny thing
about being immortal is that it makes
your time utterly worthless death is a
fantastic motivator because it means
that no matter how many times you save
yourself i'll just do it later you know
that someday there will be no more later
it starts a fire under you and gets you
moving but when you're immortal like dr
bright thanks to his
scp-963 medallion there's always going
to be a later to foist your problems
onto until the sun expands and devours
the earth in billions of years is time
today however dr bright decided to spend
his time looking into the rates of
containment breaches at site 19 and
pondering how exactly he could reduce
these numbers site 19 had impeccable
security and a wide range of elite
containment specialists but while these
factors can help address containment
breaches when they happen dr bright
wanted to instead treat the cause of
containment breaches rather than
treating them symptomatically in other
words rather than preventing successful
breaches from anomalies dr bright wanted
to figure out how to stop anomalies from
wanting to breach containment in the
first place that's when he had a
brainwave a few weeks earlier he'd read
an article about the revolutionary
norwegian prison system which used a
high quality of life in prison with a
great degree of inmate enrichment to
slash recidivism rates this to dr bright
seemed like a fascinating idea if he
gave a bunch of the more problematic
sentient and sapient anomalies better
enrichment then perhaps they'd be too
busy enjoying themselves to want to
break out and cause chaos elsewhere and
dr bright had an ingenious way of
finding the right enrichment for the
many anomalies under site 19's care and
even beyond he'd give them computers or
smartphones with fixed access to
amazon.com where they could build up
their wish lists and give him a starting
point for what kind of objects and
activities might be ideal enrichment for
each of the anomalies in question as far
as dr bright figured there would be no
way that his new plan could possibly go
wrong all he needed to do was get
started so over the next several days dr
bright devoted himself to giving a
convocative anomalies devices locked on
the amazon app and told them to spend
some time browsing adding any items that
they thought they might like to the wish
list for later consideration it was the
exact kind of deranged genius that only
a maverick like jack bright could muster
and in the days and hours that followed
reams of fascinating data rolled in huge
numbers of anomalies picked incredibly
bizarre products for their wish lists
and in seeing which anomalies picked he
got an unprecedented look into the minds
of some of the foundation's most
infamous inmates and of course we're
going to tell you about some of the
craziest ones what kind of monsters
would we be to play those cards close to
our chest these are some of the weirdest
amazon products that the different
anomalies added to their wish lists and
we're sorry to inform you it's gonna get
even wilder after that first to bring
things full circle there's scp-682
who was temporarily dragged out of the
acid tank he's permanently melting in
and given an iphone after eating the
first three iphones and throwing the
next several at guards at such
incredible speeds that it caused
considerable injuries he finally
begrudgingly agreed to play along after
scrolling for a considerable amount of
time 682 added bacon strip bandages
which he intended to gift to guards and
researchers to make them taste better he
also added a taco sleeping bag for the
exact same reasons and the exotic needs
beef jerky because honestly foundation
staff and dead cows get a little samey
after a while and yes before you ask
everything featured in this video is an
incredibly weird real amazon product we
honestly kind of wish we were kidding
next dr bright started collecting the
data from
scp-106's wish list the deranged and
sadistic old man seemed to enjoy nothing
but doling out pain to his victims but
given the seemingly limitless purview of
amazon he went a little nuts first he
added the hatch your own spider's
terrarium perhaps believing that filling
his pocket dimension with thousands of
spiders would make it an even more
delightfully miserable place for his
victims as a delicious snack fit for an
evil old anomalous lunatic he decided to
add some canned edible smoked
rattlesnake and of course he threw on a
human head stress ball so he could
simulate torturing a human head without
actually needing to access one dr bright
was fascinated by the bizarre spectrum
of results so far so he next moved on to
the amazon wish list of scp-076-2
also known as abel with whom dr bright
had a long-standing grudge abel upon
resurrection had to be restrained by a
massive amount of industrial strength
straps typically used to hold elephants
in place during surgery after a solid 48
hours of relentless struggling they were
finally able to get able to dictate his
wish list picks to a foundation
researcher at a nearby computer his
first pick was predictably a chef's
choice treiser xv edge select
professional electric knife sharpener
for completely obvious reasons he then
added the book called weapons a
pictorial history for some light reading
around his favorite subject and of
course he also added a vast collection
of temporary tattoos because it'd been a
while since he got his last badass
battle tat but didn't quite feel ready
to commit to something at this time next
came
scp-2273 major alexei bellatrov an
alternate history's russian militant
trapped in a biomechanical weapon of war
he first added an oversized bread pillow
which made him nostalgic for the russian
breadline days of his childhood next he
threw on a self-sustaining aquatic
ecosphere after all in his native
timeline almost all life was wiped out
by nuclear war it brought him great
comfort to have a handheld reminder that
life still goes on somewhere and also he
treated himself to a handheld pump
operated fart vacuum because whenever he
farted in his exo suit and was just
stuck there with it it was a truly
hellish experience of course dr bright
couldn't resist trying out his
experiment with scp-049
also known as the plague doctor one of
the scp foundation's more intellectual
captives predictably the first item
added to his wish list was a 157 piece
set of stainless steel surgical tools
next in a fun twist of fate the plague
doctor decided to add a realistic rubber
pigeon mask to his wish list when dr
bright later questioned him about this
he said well dear boy this is one of the
only masks i've ever seen that will
actually fit over my head he then added
an insulated tote bag with the words
human organ for transplant printed on
the side funnily enough he'd probably be
the only one to actually use it for
human organs next came scp-029 also
known as the daughter of shadows dr
bright was particularly eager to include
this extremely violent ketter class in
his new experiment because she attempted
escape from containment constantly so it
would save a lot of money and lives to
keep her pacified when she stopped
trying to strangle the staff member
giving her the iphone she first selected
a skull-shaped makeup brush holder which
satisfied two of her greatest passions
death and being adored she also bought
an instructional book called
a girl's guide to femdom and a blu-ray
copy of indiana jones and the temple of
doom next came the kind but haunted
scp-073
also known as kane the first addition to
his wish list was a pair of flip-flops
with artificial grass along the sole to
simulate the sensation of walking on
grass seeing as kane can't walk on real
grass without killing it these grassy
sandals would naturally give him some
comfort next he added the instructional
book dancing for cats so he could
practice his dance moves with josie the
half cat aka
scp-529 and in a bizarre turn of events
he bought 30 pieces of fake garlic so he
could fantasize about touching garlic
without it immediately dying next came
scp-811 the sweet but simple-minded
humanoid amphibian known as the swamp
woman would her amazon wishlist also be
esoterically wholesome like the anomaly
herself first she added a stuffed
blobfish plush commenting ah
him so sweet upon clicking add to
wishlist she next added a novelty
yodeling pickle the mere idea which
brought her a great deal of amusement
she also bought a talking hamster toy
largely due to being extremely lonely
most days in containment and even being
willing to tolerate a pretend rodent
with a preset selection of phrases as a
social substitute next came the
disembodied brain of the mad inventor
jeremy valdez also known to the scp
foundation as scp-2099
as soon as the terminally scatterbrained
brain made up his mind dr bright
reviewed the list first he added a book
called the brain that changes itself
next he nab some pretty dubious brain
supplements that the amazon reviews
suggest give the user rather violent
diarrhea and bafflingly a dill pickle
flavored tube of lip balm no we don't
know how dr valdez intends to use that
either dr bright also gave an iphone
locked onto the amazon app to dr clef
who isn't an anomaly contained by the
scp foundation but was still bizarre and
enigmatic enough that dr bright was
eager to psychoanalyze him via his
amazon wishlist selections first he
selected a book entitled shotguns a
comprehensive guide next he threw on an
extensive ukulele repair kit and of
course a pooping pooch's calendar stay
classy dr cleff dr bright performed this
exact experiment on hundreds of
different anomalies gaining what he
believed to be invaluable data that
could help enrich the containment of so
many of them and thus prevent countless
containment breaches this had been such
a brilliant plan dr bright felt beyond
pleased with himself until he received
an incredibly angry sounding phone call
from 05-1 jack you over-hyped piece of
gaudy jewelry what the hell have you
done this time dr bright was deeply
confused as to why the o5 council were
so angry at him he'd been performing one
of the most benign experiments in the
history of the scp foundation he hadn't
even needed to kill a single d-class so
why all the vitriol moments later though
dr bright would discover the horrifying
error of his ways you see when dr bright
had given these hundreds of anomalies
iphones with location services enabled
and the amazon app open he'd also
forgotten to log out of his account
which incidentally was also twined to
his scp foundation expenses account in
essence the various anomalies of the scp
foundation had ordered tens of thousands
of dollars worth of the most bizarre
amazon products imaginable and they were
heading straight for site 19. the waste
of money would be bad enough but the
true threat was far more grave this
little mistake had exposed the location
of the scp foundation's biggest
containment site to one of its most
powerful enemies and by the looks of
things he was already on his way
not long after the fateful order was
made a fleet of amazon branded attack
helicopters choked the skies while
fleets of amazon ground vehicles
approached site 19 in tight formation
mobile task forces and guards converged
around the perimeter of the site hoping
to fend off the coming attack but even
they were overwhelmed by the sheer
extent of the force coming towards them
dr bright horrified at the chaos he'd
wrought ran to the front lines outside
the site ready to take on the new threat
with the foundation's finest that's when
the line of vehicles came to a stop and
the helicopters continued circling in
the sky doors opened and heavily armed
soldiers and tactical gear began to
spill out it was an army like nothing dr
bright or the foundation had ever seen
before the army split like the red sea
and their great and terrible leader
stepped forwards muscles rippling out
from the sleeves of his overpriced hugo
boss vest it was him
ceo entrepreneur born in 1964
jeffrey bezos
one of the world's most ruthless
businessmen with biceps that could bust
skulls like he busted unions and little
known the fact he's a man with close
ties to the incredibly wealthy group of
interest marshall carter and dark
limited he was here for one reason and
one reason only
to acquire the scp foundation
and add it to his world devouring
conglomerate of evil
don't worry dr bright he said with a
devious smirk not much will change under
my management i already treat my
employees like d-class personnel
[Laughter]
but dr bright would never see the scp
foundation taken over by such a
heartless self-interested lex luthor
wannabe he challenged jeff bezos to a
one-on-one battle to decide the fate of
the scp foundation seeing as it was his
fault and his fault alone that the
location of site 19 had been revealed to
bezos and his underpaid minions bezos
agreed to the terms and the battle began
dr bright put up his dukes and prepared
to tussle bezos however flexed his
muscles so inhumanly hard that his vest
and shirt exploded into shreds revealing
his surprisingly small physique
underneath little did dr bright know
bezos had augmented his body with nano
machines to massively increase his
strength and durability he was now a
combatant of truly anomalous power how
would dr bright possibly win the two ran
towards each other across the
battlefield outside of site 19 both
roaring in animal rage ready for this
clash of the titans that would determine
the fate of the scp foundation forever
long story short dr bright said to dr
hayburg who at this point was thoroughly
confused everything was okay in the end
see it's important not to dwell on our
mistakes uh
thanks dr bright i guess he said i'm
sure if anything dr bright just said to
him was true or if it was all some
complex free associating fantasy he made
up on the spot dr bright gave him a
playful punch on the shoulder anytime
rookie anytime now go check out scp-963
what would you do if you were immortal
like dr jack bright and dr bright for
president
scp-4444 bush vs gore for more wacky
misadventures from the immortally silly
dr bright